[Applause]
[Music]
norway it's famous for its extreme
climate of long
sunny summer days and long dark winter
nights as well as the extreme cold
they're also famous for their welfare
state like any other nordic country but
perhaps most of all they're famous for
their smoked salmon
[Music]
and it's not just us at visualpolitik
who think this actually the fishing
industry is one of the most
modern and important in the world
however in the last few years the most
significant element of the norwegian
identity has been its commitment
to the environment especially its fight
against climate change
and there is no better place for us to
see this than in their adoption
of the electric car you see norway has
the most developed market of electric
cars
in the world in norway you'll find that
one of every two cars sold is either
electric
or it's a hybrid but there's even more
to this because by 2025 which is kind of
basically tomorrow norway expects to
stop
selling gas or diesel-powered cars
altogether they only want to sell
electric
and hybrid cars now this might be pretty
hard to imagine right i mean it's been a
hundred years of combustion engines and
it all seems as if it's about to come to
an end
at least in norway
here electric car mania well it's even
reached ships
two companies are currently developing a
project called tesla of the seas its
goal is to launch the first autonomous
ship that's powered by
electric batteries the first yara
birkeland the formal name of the project
is expected to be ready by the end of
and this might all leave you wondering
well what's norway's secret how on earth
have they made
electric cars quite so popular is it
really all to do about just concern for
the environment
well yeah i mean maybe that is a part of
it but if we're honest the majority
reason well it's a little less
idealistic the key for this electric car
boom
it's got everything to do with the tax
incentives that the government has
granted in order to support
the industry so look in norway when you
choose to buy a vehicle you can actually
save an enormous amount in taxes
if you choose to go for an electric
vehicle for instance for one
you do not pay any v8e and in norway
that's 25
right off the bat you also don't have to
pay any registration fees or any other
additional taxes
all right so this all sounds well and
good but what is the actual result of
this all financially
so according to a recent study you got
this car the tesla model
s now if this was a regular gas car if
you included all the taxes and
everything else this thing in norway is
going to set you back about 140
000 but thanks to the tax relief of the
norwegian government this price is
actually around
seventy thousand dollars which is fifty
percent in
savings which is pretty amazing
and that's not even mentioning the other
advantages i mean these cars they don't
have to pay for any tolls and they don't
have to pay
parking meters also there's another
major advantage because in norway
electricity it's mostly hydroelectric
which means well
it's both cheap and it's clean alright
so as a result of these policies and
some other policies the government
expects to reduce
total carbon emissions by 40 percent in
the next few years
all right if you consider all of these
advantages like being able to get a
tesla for 70 grand
and the fact that it has one of the
highest living standards in the world
you might be thinking right now well
norway sounds like a pretty amazing
place but taking things back to the
environment for a minute the norwegian
constitution it even actually protects
the environment
consider article 110 every person has a
right to an environment that is
conducive to health and to a natural
environment whose productivity and
diversity are maintained
natural resources should be managed on
the basis of comprehensive long-term
considerations whereby
this right will be safeguarded for
future generations as well
article 110b of norway's constitution
alright so as always in one of these
videos not
everything is sunshine lollipops and
rainbows
so norway is this really wealthy country
and they've got this really big wealth
estate but
they do have a small issue or at least a
problem that makes greenpeace really
angry
and this issue it is about the oil
production of
norway but now the question really has
to become i mean how oil dependent
is norway well let's have a look at that
[Music]
oil addicts
if we could take a time machine back to
the beginning of the 20th century we
would find norway with a
really basic economy all they did was
fishing fishing and more fishing now if
we traveled forward in time even though
things did
improve significantly norway during the
1960s was in no way included in the list
of the world's wealthiest countries
not at all in fact its per capita income
was around half of switzerland
in 1960 the standard of living in norway
was about 30 or 40 percent lower than in
sweden or in denmark
now the standard of living in norway is
substantially higher than in those two
countries bruno gerrard
an economist at the norwegian business
school in oslo so
now the obvious question becomes well
what happened to norway how did it
become one of the richest countries on
earth
in so little time well everything began
to change
in the year 1969 this was the year when
the first oil reserves were
found and since then well it's been a
bit of a golden age the country became
one of the world's largest
oil and natural gas suppliers as you can
imagine this oil revolution means
tons of money coming in money that
contributed to building
the norway that we know today
today oil and natural gas are the keys
of this country's economy in 2016 for
instance almost
40 percent of exports and more than a
fifth of investment had its origin
in the oil and gas sector and of course
i mean the government
it's getting its share look depending on
the year and the prices of gatineau the
income that the government obtains from
this industry varies from about one of
every four to one of every six
euros of the government's total tax
collection and
when a government gets a ton of money
well that usually means an increase in
public spending
the world's most generous welfare state
leaves 20 on the door yeah that's
absolutely right to a certain extent we
could say the norwegian model of a huge
welfare state with public control of
many of the large companies has a lot to
do
with oil however the tumbling fall of
the price of this raw material has led
the government to take an incredibly
controversial measure for the first time
in 20 years the norwegian government
is granting new exploration licenses
in particular 10 new instances of oil
exploration in the barren sea
in the heart of the arctic circle
[Music]
and the truth is this movement has made
greenpeace and other environmental
organizations
really really angry greenpeace by the
way they've taken the government to
court accusing them of violating the
paris agreement
and also violating the norwegian
constitution itself as we just told you
a moment ago the environment is pretty
well protected in norwegian law
but the thing is norway's green
commitment well
it has certain limitations norway has
set out to be a global leader in climate
action
yet continued expansion of oil and gas
production could eclipse the benefits of
norway's domestic emission reduction
efforts peter erickson a senior
scientist within the stockholm
environment institute
and well the reality is that the world's
largest welfare state it
certainly does not come cheap we
as a country are petro-holics we depend
so much on the income from the oil just
like alcoholics we want to stop but we
don't know how
thomas nielsen editor of the independent
barnes observer but but
wait for a minute because it is not like
norway is like some of those other
countries that also rely on oil
absolutely not norway is dependent on
oil to a certain extent but it's not
even
close to how dependent venezuela or
saudi arabia are on it
in norway things they are totally
different now although the government
does carry a lot of economic weight
norway has tried to be open to business
and they have tried to use this oil
money to fund productive activities and
provide a quality education they have
also been
incredibly committed to saving
[Music]
the fund of funds for a country that has
made
so much money with the oil industry
norway is very different to what we are
used to oslo the capital city is not
overtaken by skyscrapers
massive malls extravagant complexes now
don't get me wrong they have spent a lot
of money but the key to norway
is that they haven't wasted it the
norwegian government they made this
really sensible decision they decided to
save a lot of their oil money they set
up a sovereign wealth fund to invest the
money and buy assets
all around the globe and this is the
biggest sovereign wealth fund
on earth not even saudi arabia not even
kuwait
have saved so much now consider this
norway's sovereign wealth fund hits one
trillion dollars
yeah that's that's absolutely right
that's a trillion dollars
this is a fortune of around 190 000
per norwegian citizen instead of wasting
this money they invested it
in companies all around the world this
fund has invested money in more than 9
000 companies in 78
countries some of these companies are
really famous you got apple nestle shell
alphabet that's better known as google
yeah indeed we could say that the
norwegians well they even own a part of
youtube and you know what one of their
targets is to eventually
replace their oil income with income
from these investments i mean these are
investments they produce
profit it's what they do and these
profits have been a return of about 5.7
a year so if these levels of return were
to be kept the same norway would have an
average of 50 billion dollars in profit
which is equivalent to about 25 percent
of their public spending starting to
sound pretty good right and on top of
all of that of course there's the income
that the government gets from oil and
local companies
companies that despite being state-owned
they do work with market criteria
all right so it's still looking pretty
rosy i mean you might be thinking right
now that
norway what does it have to worry about
but hold on for just a moment
because the welfare level it does seem
to have a solid base but the government
is absolutely determined to achieve
economic diversification in order to
have a more competitive economy so that
they
ultimately get rid of their dependency
on oil
the reforms
[Music]
since 1927 the center-left party has
been the most popular
in general elections but in norway
absolute majorities they're not really
common
in 2013 a coalition of center-right-wing
parties like the progress party famous
for its radical position on immigration
managed to put ernest solberg in office
she is known as the norwegian version of
angela merkel
in the recent elections that happened on
the 11th of september 2017 this
coalition when it was re-elected
and the intent of this government is to
get some distance from what has become
known as the norwegian
model the government they want to
improve the competitiveness of the
country by reducing taxes
especially for companies both public and
private but at the same time they also
intend to keep developing the oil
[Music]
industry
if they are sure about something in
norway it is that innovation and
development
are the best ways to obtain high
standards of living
and improve the environment so well now
it is your turn do you think that norway
should be this
example of something to be followed in
the management of natural resources well
do let us know your answer
in the comments below as well as in this
survey and do not forget to subscribe to
our channel for brand new videos every
monday and thursday button
below the screen now click on that also
do not forget to check out our friends
at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine and as always
thank you for watching so you're still
here still watching this video
maybe you just let it run and you're not
actually there anymore whatever the case
if you're listening to this i think you
should go check out my new channel it's
called biographics it is biographies of
notable historic figures
as well as present day people let me
give you some examples we got the queen
of england
vladimir putin those just two people on
the world schedule's got elon musk
coming up arnold schwarzenegger
we even the first serial killer h h h
homs maybe just h.h homs we look at all
sorts of people
longer form about 20 minutes long diving
into the story of their lives in a
similar style to this
it's biographics if you like this
channel if you like my other stuff
you're gonna like this as well
biographics there is a link in the
description below
do go check it out and please do
[Music]
subscribe
you